hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday November 28th 2016 that I'm doing
on November 29th a Tuesday what's going
on how are ya
um I am okay in case you were wondering
I got a little uh I know I got a little
I've been fighting off this car for like
two [ __ ] weeks who's kidding who
right and I you know I was fighting it
off and I was getting worse and Nia kept
going why don't you take some medicine
why don't you take take some of this
mucinex
all right holy [ __ ] half [ __ ] my hats
off to anybody that can get [ __ ]
drunk off their that stuff Jesus Christ
that's like peppermint schnapps times
[ __ ] 20 I really asked mucinex is
like schnapps on steroids it's just you
know one of the you know the others have
these dumb champ challenges like the
mannequin challenge I don't understand
what is the challenge just hold still if
somebody pans around the room that's a
[ __ ] challenge how the [ __ ] did we go
from faking a lunar landing faking that
faking out the whole [ __ ] Russians
they got so freaked out that they day
went they went on a hissy fit for the
next [ __ ] thirty years before they
finally went broke right in the early
90s because we accepted the challenge of
the faking of the lunar lamb maybe even
got there the lunar landing challenge
now a [ __ ] other mannequin Oh
planking yeah I lay face down and
somebody takes a picture of me Jesus
Christ I don't know what the you know
what it is is these [ __ ] goddamn
[ __ ] young people these days you know
no offense right god bless you let's a
[ __ ] spend their whole lives with
these [ __ ] reality virtual reality
goddamn things on their head they played
video games they don't have any skills
the second you take the [ __ ] laptop
you take the [ __ ] laser tag thing the
paint gun whatever the [ __ ] technology
is the thing that you know that new
thing that they're trying to get old
people into the virtual reality like
like living a [ __ ] life is it isn't
enough like I want to leave this [ __ ]
world
really
you saw it all you been to Venice rode a
boat through the [ __ ] canal done [ __ ]
alright so this is a deal
they don't [ __ ] know how to [ __ ]
do anything this is such an old man rent
that just [ __ ] literally laying face
down in the road you know and somebody
takes a picture is is this it's it's
epic
it's [ __ ] epic granted in the 70s
they did have pet rock so I might be
full of [ __ ] but you know what it is the
great thing about being old is you lack
perspective when you talk about anything
new you just like that's different it
scares me I don't get the mannequin
challenge I don't you know and that that
was like dating to hell so had the
whatever the Harlem shake was initially
it was a dance and then it was just that
stupid YouTube thing the ice bucket
challenge all of that [ __ ] you know if
your instincts aren't immediately to not
be part of the group I don't know what
that says about you I don't want to
sense about me that I mean the ice
bucket or everybody's doing it well then
[ __ ] I'm not doing it oh antisocial
sick freckled headed bald [ __ ] what's
wrong with you today
hang on a second Ricola yes I've been
fighting this [ __ ] thing off you know
I have a bad feeling it might be want
this cigar that I got that there's
something in there some sort of bacteria
because I was fine and then I smoked
with virzi on his birthday
and then I smoked with Bobby Kelly it
[ __ ] comics come home back-to-back
nights and then I just had this [ __ ]
cough you know it's like he inhaled the
goddamn things it's not like I smoked
one every [ __ ] day I smoked one like
once every two weeks
oh they I've been a little bit of a
bender okay so anyway so Sunday night
you know it's been a good 15 days since
I smoked all right I'll smoke another
one went down with my buddy we watched
the Broncos Chiefs game arguably the
greatest Sunday night football game I
lost track of how many [ __ ] lead
changes
were just you know and I wasn't drinking
I haven't drank since Thanksgiving I
kind of bottom doubt Thanksgiving right
you know let's back I had a great
Thanksgiving by the way great [ __ ]
Thanksgiving um we ended up today talk
about that already
I think I already did maybe I didn't I
don't remember or I started talk I
hadn't gone to it yet that's right
that's what it was listen this [ __ ] we
went to somebody else's for Thanksgiving
and everything was [ __ ] delicious
every side was [ __ ] not only
delicious it was a home run
it's the best Thanksgiving I had since
I've been a kid when I ate at my parents
house you know my mother cooks so it
just automatically tastes right because
that's the only Thanksgiving you know
right but that once you move out you're
eating other people's food and no matter
what it's always a little bit different
it's not quite the same you get that
feeling of [ __ ] it's over I have to pay
rent now I'm gonna get old right I'm
gonna be that person what happened to
him and then I [ __ ] die and bla bla
bla bla bla and all that [ __ ] right
so anyways we had a great [ __ ]
Thanksgiving and I had this [ __ ]
bottle of bourbon that I brought that
was my responsibility where the [ __ ] is
my phone I gotta give this thing a
shout-out man
you know they say you can't judge a book
by its [ __ ] cover I actually judged
this bottle just by how cool the [ __ ]
bottle looked so let me scroll through
my it was called angels and something or
other by the way it rained like a
[ __ ] out here and I have water
collecting up on my roof again [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's unbelievable it's just
[ __ ] it's just it's just not even
right so I gotta get the third [ __ ]
people out here to see if they know how
to fix it nah god dammit I thought I
took a picture of it nah I gotta find it
hang on a second you know I'm we hit
pause I'll hit pause alright I found it
angels Envy it's a Kentucky Bourbon
goddamnit was that delicious and me and
two other people we finished the bottle
and I don't know I got like two my last
one and I was just like you know what I
think this I
it's time for me to shut it down you
know every once in a while the drinking
just gets a little bit too [ __ ] far
and then I just shut it down so I walked
away cold turkey Thanksgiving night cold
turkey I [ __ ] walked away from it and
you know I'm not gonna lie to you I miss
it it's only been four days I'm still
thinking about you sending it letters
and [ __ ] yeah I'm just gonna shut it
down probably until I'd say maybe the
Rose Bowl New Year's Day or whatever I
already got to shut it down and got a
[ __ ] kid coming so it's over you know
what you know what people I got to be
honest I had a great run I got the
stories you know I spent a few a few
hours in jail I mean I've done you know
went to court I had the whole you know
had to apologize to people I I had a
very full experience with alcohol you
know talk to some chicks that were way
out of my league you know I I did it I
had the whole thing you know stayed on
the outskirts of bar fights to make sure
that I didn't get pummeled so that's it
so anyways believe it or not as bad as
my cough sounds it's way better than it
was [ __ ] yesterday I was gonna wasn't
gonna put you through that [ __ ] so
anyways so Sunday night yeah smoke turn
over a little cigars and yesterday I
woke up I just hose having a [ __ ]
coffin fit granted I was already rundown
so yesterday I didn't do [ __ ] I got to
tell you that was like the greatest six
hours of my life not doing [ __ ] but
somewhere in that six hour after the six
hours I was going out of my [ __ ] mind
I don't know how you guys do it you know
not you guys just whoever the [ __ ] is
out there that just can just truly take
a goddamn day off I go [ __ ] nuts
after six hours it was great I laid
there I watched like two three episodes
of Westworld getting caught up I'm up to
like Episode six I'm gonna watch today
right
and loving that show although you can't
watch more than two or three in a day it
just too much man it's like just got to
be you know it's a lot of [ __ ] going on
to kind of take it and then also having
now doing my own little show that's only
a half hour when I look at that show I
just think of like how [ __ ] long did
it take them to do this and I'm gonna
sit here and I'm gonna watch it in two
days and then be that douche going once
season two coming out you know it's like
it's a fine bottle of wine and I'm just
gonna chug the thing you know after the
third glass I'm not really tasting it
anymore because I'm so hammered I might
as well be drinking like [ __ ] red
white and blue beer or some [ __ ] right
just doesn't seem right so anyways
that's what I did yesterday
and I'm feeling much better thank Christ
so by the way today's November 29th
which is the five year anniversary since
the passing of one of the funniest and
greatest people I ever met Patrice
O'Neal speaking of which there are still
some tickets left
for the the 5th annual Patrice O'Neal
comedy benefit all the proceeds after we
pay for the the venue of course our only
expense you know goes to all of his
loved ones it's been a tremendous
success and this year we have we have
let's get the whole lineup here for
God's sakes for God's sakes we got
Leslie Jones
we got rich Faust we got Bobby Kelly
Keith Robinson Gary Gulman Dan Soder
right and myself it's going to be
another great year of I'm just getting
to see all those people you know I never
get to see them anymore cuz I'm always
out here gigging on the road or living
out here in LA buh-buh-buh-buh-buh so
that's going to be Tuesday February 21st
at the New York City Center and you know
it's just a it's just a great event and
thank you to everybody who's come to it
in the past years and you guys have done
a wonderful thing keeping all his loved
ones comfortable and very proud of that
whole charity thing because you know as
tragic as it was that he was gone I'm
very proud of the fact that all of his
friends stepped up and that all of his
loved ones are comfortable because I
know that that's what he would have been
concerned with so with that I'm actually
doing another benefit for those who
can't make it to New York City if you're
in the LA area and you would like to
you'd like to help out on another
benefit I have another buddy of mine
that died so what happens when you get
into your 40s man it's [ __ ] brutal is
a couple your buddies died too young man
it's awful this guy peak coming I
started out with him in 1992 did
stand-up with him from 92 to 99 and then
he moved on to writing with National
Lampoon he did some stuff for the UFC
just a great guy unfortunately I had a
heart attack a few weeks ago and about a
month ago so Tuesday December 6 at the
Laugh Factory I'll be doing a headlining
set there and a bunch of Pete's friends
from back in the day a bunch of comics
we haven't all been on the same show and
forever probably 20 years we'll be going
on earlier in the night it's gonna be a
great thing and it's a memory of him so
there you go so enough with the friends
of mine that have passed away
unfortunately let's talk about some [ __ ]
here I fight I got it wah I gotta give a
shout-out to [ __ ] Nico Rosberg but in
his first Formula One Championship the
final few laps of that race were amazing
right for those of you who are not into
it basically what the situation was
Lewis Hamilton had won the last three
Nico Rosberg had never won they both
drive from Mercedes
okay so Nico's the young upstart Lewis
is the grizzled vet even though they're
both [ __ ] young it was kind of like
Days of Thunder if both both people look
like [ __ ] Tom Cruise is basically it
right it's like - Tom the old Tom Cruise
right Scientology Tom Cruise versus
[ __ ] what was that movie that they
were all in were they were the the
socials and the greasers
the [ __ ] was that movie called I knew
that one god damn it
Oh was it call Matt Dillon was in it
Emilio Estevez Estevez the dirty dancin
guy Road house guy the karate kid was in
it Tom Cruise was in it who else was in
that [ __ ] movie everybody was in that
[ __ ] movie everybody like there was
like nine people in that [ __ ] movie
they'd all went see Thomas Howell
they all went on to star in movies that
made I would love to see how much
[ __ ] box-office every every guy that
starred as a greaser in that movie ended
up making you know you gotta hate being
the one [ __ ] greaser that didn't make
it right that's when you just got to
look at yourself like dude what the [ __ ]
everybody in this ensemble cast I gotta
find out what it is now all right Tom
Cruise IMDB how do you spell cruise run
i somehow spelled it with to use hey use
Tom [ __ ] Crowes to Leo's alright there
he is smiling looking sort of normal as
normal as he possibly can well what the
outside oh the outsiders alright here we
go let's let's this this is the [ __ ]
lineup see Thomas Howell Matt Dillon
Ralph Macchio Patrick Swayze
Rob [ __ ] lo Emilio Estevez Tom Cruise
alright that alone right there one two
three four five six the first seven guys
all went on to star in movies Tom Cruise
alone has done billions in box office
Matt Dillon the amount of money he's
done Ralph Macchio the [ __ ] Karate
Kid Patrick Swayze Dirty Dancing alone
forget about ghosts right when they were
in the claymation class and when he
comes up behind her and they go all the
time of my love Whoopi Goldberg grabbing
your tits
I swear me Leo Estevez right he was in
stakeout he was in [ __ ]
The Breakfast Club he was in the cowboy
movies right he played Billy the Kid do
you come on you know all these [ __ ]
people are and you got a guy like Glenn
with row the [ __ ] happened him Diane
Lane she was in a bunt leif Garrett
Jesus Christ he sold a bunch of albums
Tom Waits was in that [ __ ] movie then
there was a William Smith who plates the
store clerk he went by William if he
went by will you know couldn't a whole
different story so anyways I don't know
what the [ __ ] him - oh yeah so Nico
Rosberg right so here's a deal the way
the points worked out was Lewis Hamilton
had them win the [ __ ] race provided
Niko didn't crash all right if Niko was
gonna finish the race Lewis had to win
the race and Niko had to become in
fourth place or worse and then Lewis
would have won his fourth in a row okay
but a lot of three PTIN out there for
not nobody who the [ __ ] does four in a
row you never see that [ __ ] right so it
comes down to the light on Niko had to
do was finish in third place and no
matter what Lewis Hamilton did this [ __ ]
was over so you get down like five
[ __ ] laps to go Nico Rosberg he's in
third place he's a [ __ ] lunatic
he passes I think it was a Red Bull car
and all guys I love the guys who
announced it they're always so [ __ ]
oh like whenever there's a Patou joke oh
god they're always doing that [ __ ] it's
like dude do you have money in that car
is that your son in there
I mean after reason we're watching this
[ __ ] is to see him crash it's like
watching hockey half-wits to watch the
game the other half is to watch somebody
beat the [ __ ] out of somebody I want to
see somebody spin around a little bit
you know I want to see a fender right so
anyways so gets in over the last five
laps Nikko goes around whoever the [ __ ]
was in second place Hulkenberg are
[ __ ] one of those other guys how Timo
mäkinen
Timo Salani I don't know any of the
other drivers yet it's my first year
watching it right he [ __ ] passes a
guy now he's in second place
so now Louis is like what the [ __ ] so
Lewis Hamilton starts slowing down
trying to let the third and fourth-place
cars catch up which they're doing
alright now they're a [ __ ] team
they're on the same team so evidently
when the head due to Mercedes you know
if you're on the Mercedes teams if your
team calls you and tells you to do
something you're not supposed to disobey
a direct order I'm telling you this is
like Top Gun and [ __ ] Days of Thunder
sorry it's just a little touch of a bowl
of people right so he gives Luke that
they give Louis a direct or to go and
Louis you got to drive faster here come
on we want to win this race and Lewis
just says he just says back into the
radio on TV basically said well I'm I'm
still in first place and I'm comfortable
with my current position basically
meaning like I'm not gonna drive any
[ __ ] faster and I'm good enough that
even if Niko's right on my ass I know
he's not gonna try to go around me you
know risking crashing because he's got
it so for the last five [ __ ] laps you
I just on the edgy a [ __ ] seat like
his this guy in third place gonna go
around Nico Rosberg he didn't
Lewis Hamilton disobeyed a direct order
I believe Robert Duvall came out in the
end and started screaming at somebody I
can't remember but it was kind of funny
like whenever like they're both on the
podium which was almost every race this
year Nico and Louis like wouldn't even
look at each other it was [ __ ] like
oh my god I'm not even talking to you
right now I'm like Sarah like not even
talking to you right now like it was
that whole [ __ ] energy so an eco wins
the thing they actually shook hands and
there was some [ __ ] clown interview
when I'm going oh I kind of blocked the
shot can you guys do that again it was
great and then they just sort of
grudgingly shook hands or whatever and
the guy just goes on like that's like
dude it's very far from all good again
so I believe the season starts up again
either the end of March or the beginning
of April and I jumped on this year after
they raced in Monaco and I had a great
time [ __ ] watching it I actually
started to think of the
your amount of [ __ ] money it must
cost to have a goddamn to run a Formula
One team I can't imagine how much
[ __ ] money you got a ship that car
around the [ __ ] world like nine times
and you know you got a couple of other
cars you got to bring with it it's got
to cost you a billion dollars it has to
does it bill
have you ever tried to ship even your
[ __ ] Prius to Connecticut No
so then you really don't know how much
it costs all right you got me whatever I
know it's gotta cost a lot of [ __ ]
money there all right
so anyways anybody watched Ohio State
Michigan I know this is kind of old
games but I don't give a [ __ ] did you
guys watch that it's one of the best
games I've seen between those two in a
long [ __ ] time and Michigan just kept
[ __ ] up when they got the ball they
had the goddamn game one do you notice
how what's-his-face they're the whatever
reason I can never remember their last
name the [ __ ] coached in Michigan Jim
Harbaugh do you notice he was wearing
the Woody Hayes glasses I actually had a
theory that if they won he was gonna
take the glasses off on their [ __ ]
logo on the 50-yard line and steps stomp
on him you know like after Jewish people
get married they step on the [ __ ]
glass he was gonna do that with the
[ __ ] his his Woody Hayes glasses I'd
love that he called out the referee and
and all that [ __ ] you know not saying I
hundred percent agreed with them and all
that [ __ ] but uh you know I thought they
got the call right on that first down I
stood up to when I saw a live action I
was like yeah and then I saw [ __ ] he got
it I thought he got it anyways but all
my Michigan buddies they were all
texting me that was a home job and all
this type of [ __ ] so who do you like
guys it's probably gonna be Alabama
right that had a nice had an easy time
with [ __ ] Auburn you see the kicker
for Auburn you grew up in an Alabama
family roll tide family and Alabama
didn't give him a scholarship so you
mean he goes to [ __ ] Auburn now and
his grandfather calls him turncoat
[ __ ] lunatics down there writes gary
Danielson the whole game keeps going
goes turncoat kickin it for three
I didn't think this podcast is remotely
funny but maybe maybe just laughing at
me coughing up a [ __ ] lung here
anyway so it's going to be Alabama and
I'm gonna say it's gonna be Ohio State
for the championship when his old Billy
red face having only watched about 15
college games this year having never
played beyond the third grade level this
is my prediction
alright organized anyways I played
enough pickup football for the first
time ever threw up my back was playing
[ __ ] football and it's never been the
same you know you know it's not the
first time first time was when that kid
put me in the figure-four leglock in
fourth grade out to a recess that's the
first time I threw it out the next time
was playing football and then the third
time was another wrestling thing I tried
to lift my younger brother up over my
head like Tony Atlas and the the upper
third if my spine folded it felt like
and you know that's given me problems
ever since then you know it's probably
why I leaned on the mic stick
anyways plot ahead here I think it's
gonna be it's gonna be [ __ ] Ohio
State Alabama
obviously I'm picking the number one and
two teams and I think Alabama beats Ohio
State this time simply because I thought
Ohio State had a lot of problems with
that defense there in Michigan and I
think Alabama's defense is even better
and Alabama's offense is not going to
make the [ __ ] mistakes that
Michigan's offense made you know you
don't watch an Alabama team and they
fumble a [ __ ] snap on the one-yard
line they just don't do [ __ ] like that
you know what I mean
cuz what's-his-face Nick Saban that
lunatic you he probably [ __ ]
waterboard you how angry a dude you know
that guy makes me feel good about my
anger when I see that guy I was joking
about this I did Jeff's a Serio's
podcast and we will [ __ ] joking about
my favorite [ __ ] thing to do is to
watch Alabama going in like down by
seven and half time I love when the
halftime reporter comes up and starts
talking to Nick Saban and in the the
look of [ __ ]
anger on his face all he wants to do is
go in the locker room and call
everybody's mother a [ __ ] that's wearing
his uniform right and but he's got to
sit there and talk to some chick on the
side like going like so why do you think
it is your dad by 8:00 yes it just sit
they you know he just wants to slap the
wig right off her [ __ ] head but he
doesn't do it he doesn't do it he sits
there with this [ __ ] I don't know
what it is on his head
you know he makes Donald Trump look like
[ __ ] uh Fabio I'm trying to think of
some of us good here who the [ __ ] even
has good hair and you never even know
anymore right everybody goes around they
get they get the troops from the back
you know peeling but the potatoes get
put out right up on the front line now
is that what they do then everybody goes
swimming and nobody knows what's going
on
all right tell you takes a real man like
myself to walk around looking like
Charlie Brown I'm telling you redheaded
Charlie Brown
anyways let's read some advertising here
for this week everybody let's see what
we got here on the docket how about
those Bruins finally won in a game right
second I start watching they go into a
three-game [ __ ] skid just let you
know what a big but a big you cannot put
a price on what Zdeno Chara brings to
this Boston Bruin defense
all right frame bridge all right if you
previously listen to this show you've
heard me talk about frame bridge hey
relax okay
some people fast-forward through these
things they mate they make it super easy
and affordable to cuss to custom frame
your favorite things you got a nice dick
pic they got the frame for you from art
and prints and posters to the photos on
your phone they're expert team hand
crafts each custom frame here in the US
hand crafts it I thought they just
measured it they handcraft this thing
and we'll send it to you in days not
weeks or months all right that's why
you're gonna love frame bridge
that's why sending a custom framed
picture with frame bridge is the go to
gift this holiday season that's a great
gift you don't any [ __ ] money just
frame a cell phone picture you and the
other person just write like friends or
I'll put a little emoji on it nice is
beautiful these guys gonna save you a
ton of money in a few minutes you can
build and order a thoughtful personal
gift on frame bridge comms website or
straight from your phone their expert
team will handcraft a custom frame or
just measure it a picture of frame that
[ __ ] fits it right for your picture
will driven straight to you or someone
on your list
and the best part frame bridge starts at
just $39 and shipping is free in a few
minutes you can create a meaningful
custom gift for everyone in your list a
picture of your sibling for you know you
what you guys got to do for Christmas
just get a [ __ ] just take a selfie of
yourself and then send it to frame
bridge then get a handcrafted photo and
just you know send it to everybody
my gift to all of you this holiday
season is a picture of me this way even
though when I'm not there I can always
be there alright pick the perfect frame
at frame bridge comm you can preview
your item in all their frame styles then
upload a picture you can even frame an
Instagram photo the talent experts at
frame bridge will print and frame your
item and ship it straight to you or your
loved one your gift arrives in days
completely ready to hang and includes a
handwritten gift note that frame bridge
helped you win the holidays with a
thoughtful gift that's easy right now
you all you got to do is go to frame
bridge comm and use the promo code BRR
you'll save 15% off your first order
and remember place your orders by
December 18th to ensure delivery by
Christmas
that's promo code bar holiday deadline
is December 18th ok next up on the
docket on it Joe Rogan's company on it
has a new product it's called emulsified
MCT oil the [ __ ] is that MCT oil is one
of the fastest sources of clean fuel for
the body in the brain it's one of the
best ways to power up your performance a
kickstart a weight management program
there's a well there are lots of MCT oil
brands out there I didn't know that but
there's none like a multi fight MCT oil
from
on it available in three delicious
flavors coconut vanilla and strawberry
oh my DNA coconut head vanilla skin
emulsified MCT oil makes mixes like a
cream easily in your more like Gary
Sheffield you rub it on your arms it and
your morning coffee without the need for
a blender no mess no cleanup you can
even mix it into your favorite foods
right now if you go to onit dot-com
slash bill you can get on its own Mull
supplied MCT oil for twelve percent off
that's on it calm did I just girl bill
to get a mole suffice / bill to get a
multiplied MCT oil for twelve percent
off for any reason if you don't like it
they'll give you your money back no
questions asked but just mean muggy as
you walk out the store they're all
[ __ ] checked got those neck muscles
you know like they could shrug their
shoulders for days why cuz it taken
their emulsified MCT oil you got nothing
to lose go to onatopp comm slash bill
now and get on it alright how many more
of these [ __ ] we got three more
let's get the first three out of the way
what do you say tipsy elves everyone
it's not a poor note by the way tipsy
elves have you ever wanted to take
advantage of an elf but it wasn't drunk
enough welcome to tipsy elves everyone
everyone needs an ugly Christmas sweater
this time of year if you want bragging
rights for the most talked about sweater
at your Christmas parties listen up
talk about your tipsy elves sweater and
other products you saw on this website
oh god this is like a [ __ ] hipster
website Oh
tipsy elves has hundreds of Christmas
sweaters designs that are nothing like
you've seen before they're not for the
faint of heart check out the all-new
2016 sweaters you won't find them
anywhere else tipsy elves sweaters are
all about fun but are serious on quality
and construction when you're shopping
for your ugly sweater check out the
other holiday and collegiate attire for
yourself or as a gift like adult onesies
what is that feet pajamas with like a
[ __ ] cutout
huh you got like a [ __ ] what do they
call that when the chicks at the truck
stop and it's just the hull the guy
sticks a glory hole you got a glory hole
in the front you know they made out of
wood their wood pajamas and you just
stick your dick through the [ __ ] then
knocked out not in the wood I for Men
interactive sweaters beer pong cornhole
and Christmas suits I didn't want to
know what that is for women holiday
leggings sweater dresses and pajamas
right now my listeners get 20% off tipsy
elves calm on anything they order on
their site shop now so you have the best
selection to choose from and you have
the you have it in time for your ugly
Christmas sweater party go to tipsy
elves calm enter my code bar and check
out to get 20% off site-wide discounts
that's tipsy elves calm / BER right
no tipsy elves calm and then my code
burr alright are you kidding me oh I
still got three more to go
alright [ __ ] this dude [ __ ] this okay
let's plow ahead where are we 32 minutes
in was there anything else I wanted to
[ __ ] talk about I'll dude I started
going through my [ __ ] cuz I'm selling my
Prius right so I'm going back and I'm
trying to find the title to my car of
course I can't find this [ __ ] thing
and I find the title to my wife's car to
my car in my old truck and I also found
a copy of a title to this 88 Honda
Accord
I had like [ __ ] 15 years ago I had
the DX was the LXE had the LX five-speed
manual transmission what a great [ __ ]
car that was god damn it I loved that
car I found a copy of that but nothing
for the Prius so now I got to go [ __ ]
to the DMV and get a copy of it and all
that [ __ ] end up getting rid of that
[ __ ] move on with my [ __ ] life yeah
and I got a [ __ ] goddamn conference
call coming up in ten minutes I'll have
to finish the rest of the podcast later
I apologize you know it's what it is
Patriots Jets did you watch that how
[ __ ] awful that our defense look in
the
[ __ ] half good lord um I mean I know
we're banged up and everything but uh I
don't know remember that time when we
traded Richard Seymour a long time ago
in every Patriot fan was like dude what
the [ __ ] did we do that for and then the
people who were kind of paying attention
were like well look it was a deal next
year he's gonna be up for free agency he
was gonna ask for a zillion dollars and
we knew we weren't gonna give it to him
and then we would have got nothing for
him so he traded in the year before I
went on this website and they showed all
that to trickle down from that thing
that trade and all the players we got
how we could be more aggressive because
of what we got force Richard Seymour I'm
hoping the same thing is that happened
this year with I didn't know if we trade
Chandler Jones or we lost him to free
agents free agency but uh the [ __ ]
dude that we sent to Cleveland which I
keep from Jamie Collins maybe that'll
turn into something but uh I don't know
it's unhealthy as we are I'm not I don't
know I'm not giving up I never came up
I'm just saying you know what the [ __ ]
it's the goddamn Jets they were [ __ ]
going crazy to every [ __ ] play they
made they were going [ __ ] nuts you
know like they just [ __ ] like that
was their playoff game which I respected
they [ __ ] came to play but anyways so
this whole [ __ ] weekend all I did was
watch football and I and I was looking
for that title and in the process of
looking for the title I cleaned up a
bunch of my [ __ ] and I was kind of
thinking with a kid coming along
I'm not gonna have time to do [ __ ] but
life is gonna keep hitting me so I want
to know where all my insurance forms are
or every [ __ ] piece of legal [ __ ]
that I need you know what I mean like
the agya tracking number and all that
I'm getting all of that stuff organized
and I had all these [ __ ] [ __ ] that I
held on to front I had like [ __ ] my
insurance auto insurance contract from
like 2007 until now and I'm like it
expires 12 months after you get a bill
you've held on to this [ __ ] for nine
years longer than you need to so I
shredded a lot of [ __ ] but uh underrated
just finally going through your office
and just
organizing everything I kind of know
where like everything is now and I want
to I want to do that kind of for
everything that I have so when my kid
comes here and then takes a marker out
and draws all over everything I'll know
where the [ __ ] insurance [ __ ] is all
right let's let's read um let's read
some some questions here for the week
Stanhope special this is somebody
writing it about the great Doug Stanhope
said hey Bill used your promo code to
sign up for C so so I could watch
Stanhope's new special I've heard
nothing but great things he said holy
[ __ ] you're still my favorite bill but
Stanhope is a genius why do you guys
always have to do that you're still
gonna take the piss out of me
I know he's [ __ ] tremendous you know
why can't you just say this guy's a
great kameena date bill all right Peggy
but this guy over here yeah everybody
the Internet's got to do that if you
have a good band
someone's got us just sit there and be
like dude I love you guys but it's
[ __ ] Doug Stanhope man he's a [ __ ]
I know he's a genius you don't have to
take the piss out of me he's [ __ ]
better than I am [ __ ] [ __ ] he said I
wish more people knew about him I felt
the same way about you years ago when
you were just a comedy baby tell you
people at Netflix to give him the
Chappelle treatment I Love You Man
yeah I've heard nothing but great [ __ ]
about that I'm sorry that's the last of
the Laurie Cola eat another Mike kind of
a [ __ ] amateur am i all right well
what you're telling me every comedian
has known about Doug Stanhope since
probably the late 90s and Doug is ever
watch those cop movies you know you know
that guy you always have to turn in his
badge cuz he's doing [ __ ] outside the
system but he's got a good heart and in
the end he arrests the bad guy and it's
all good that's who Stanhope is right
but the entertainment industry hasn't
figured that out yet but eventually he
will be standing on their [ __ ] City
Hall steps as they give him the key to
the city that's what I'm hoping but my
rule with all of these guys is I don't
watch this stand-up special just because
I can't have an hour and an hour and a
half of
[ __ ] floating around in my head cuz
it'll influence you know I'm a too
paranoid about that but my rule is there
with all these guys Rogan stanhope Louie
Chappelle all of these guys that if they
come into a comedy club that I'm at and
they're gonna go do a set I will watch
him that's how I do it but I don't watch
their specials because I'm too paranoid
about any sort of overlap or whatever
but um
having said that every time Doug
Stanhope specials come out
always always always feel like three to
six months afterwards comics that just
take me aside gonna do it have you seen
stand up stand [ __ ] special
yeah he's [ __ ] incredible and I don't
know well I don't know why I don't know
why what it is about comics like that
that they just I don't know if the
industry just won't give the same I
don't you know what it is at the end of
the day well if you ever have a question
about an artist you like just imagine
Doug Stanhope on TV trying to sell your
Ritz crackers okay how long could he
talk about those crackers before they
would have a major [ __ ] prodding
that's when it comes down to all right
there's the people that are truly are
the greats and then there's the people
that are really good but they won't
[ __ ] you know they can sell a box of
Ritz crackers that's what it kind of
comes down to and Doug Stanhope is one
of those [ __ ] guys what makes them
great so maybe that's what it is
I like that this guy's like that you got
to have the [ __ ] rogue guys you know
what I mean you can't have everybody
just [ __ ] hanging out with I don't
know Eddie showbiz you know in a [ __ ]
you know an election party you don't
mean and talking about issues
hi I'm [ __ ] sandy San Sam cakes and
I'm here to talk about the [ __ ] the
slaughter of baby seals and all of that
you know that mainstream like step off
your private jet take the time to give a
[ __ ] for twenty minutes before you get
back to you
your personal assistant there's that
level of connecting with people and then
there's what Stanhope does where he
[ __ ] goes where they're at that guy
is literally played I would say you know
let's say this 10,000 comedy clubs in
this country he's played at least 9,998
of them that [ __ ] guy has played as
much as I've done a bunch of play that
guy has been [ __ ] everywhere and
that's why that's why he's as good as he
is that his work ethic he's [ __ ]
prolific he's one of my favorites of all
time so I wish I knew what the name of
this special was maybe I can like go to
look at I'll look that up you know what
I gotta get pause like at this [ __ ]
conference call I'll be right back and I
also have the name of the special what
do you think about that and this will be
like [ __ ] like an eighth of a second
in your life just like those [ __ ]
Millennials with their virtual reality
glasses what's that over there which guy
I [ __ ] hate that commercial where the
kids are sitting there freaking the [ __ ]
out like they don't realize that it's
not a real world and then the greedy
corporate [ __ ] then what have they got
to do they got to have the old
curmudgeon guy like me actually older
than me and then you know what are you
kids do and then he puts it on and then
of course he's completely enamored right
and now he's gonna be into the [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] those glasses
I swear to god man like the amount of
people that are gonna get mugged while
they have those [ __ ] things on in
public because I'll tell you right now
these [ __ ] kids are so goddamn stupid
they're wearing one of those and like on
a city bus and just [ __ ] have it on
there you know what I mean it's like
walking into like one of those little
[ __ ] baskets with what Cobra in there
and you stick your head in with your
virtual reality glass glasses and you
can't see the snake anymore because
you're in [ __ ] middle-earth the old
man's coming out of me this week alright
hang on a second all right now back just
like that an hour a [ __ ] conference
calling huh don't you wish you with me
is there anything better than a
conference call hey let's get on and
make a call and have a conference
everybody can talk and share ideas
have another are you life go by that
you're never gonna get back all right
you know this how old I am
you know what's on my Christmas list
this year you know it is pajamas I've
had the same pair of [ __ ] pajamas for
like I don't even know how long like I
don't know maybe early 2000s you know
I'm trying to think all this [ __ ] that
I've watched on TV and these Jam jams
and they've just had it it's [ __ ]
over
and I've actually dropped not even the
hint I just demanded and you get that
when you get to be my age cuz no one
gives a [ __ ] about you anymore you can't
ask for something for Christmas you got
to start you got to make demands with
like a touch of a threat okay I'm just
saying they've been be some Jam jams
under the [ __ ] tree T um anyways and
then no matter what then you end up
being wrong like I had a [ __ ]
argument with my wife this week about
the way she [ __ ] you know stacks up
the dishes in the sink you don't I mean
I don't know if your wife does this [ __ ]
but there'll be like a pot sitting in
the [ __ ] sink and then they have a
plate right what do they do they stick
the plate on top of the thing and then
they take another bowl and they stick it
on top of the plate and then you just
got this leaning tower of horseshit
and your [ __ ] sink it's like why
don't you put the plate underneath the
pot and then just see if the pot can fit
in the bowl the ball could fit in the
[ __ ] pot and then it takes like a
third of the space you know you ever
think a doer to that [ __ ] gate you
know make it right rather make it look
like this ten weeks of [ __ ] dishes
here this is like two meals you know one
of those [ __ ] one of those [ __ ]
dumb arguments where you end up getting
in your car and driving away and then
afterwards you just sitting there going
what the [ __ ] I'm literally driving down
the street right now contemplating
giving this woman everything that I own
and moving into a one-bedroom apartment
over
way she stacks dishes in the sink but
I'll tell you when you live with
somebody
it seems so [ __ ] important all right
time off dear Billy body I think you're
awesome thank you and admittedly I have
a crush on you and I'm a lay there you
go
I thought the left term was gonna be and
I'm a dude I love that you take care of
yourself and are always striving to be
better this is great I think you know
what if I were you guys listening to
this right now I would be highly suspect
of whether or not I actually wrote this
in my husband and I haven't seen you
live yet and we want we want to this
year if you happen to be coming back to
Wisconsin well where the hell were you a
few months ago you know when you develop
this crush in October I was there in
September do you think you'll be touring
as much or will you be taking the year
off to spend time with your newborn love
you and I love Nia oh I'm totally gonna
be the absentee father if I already have
that worked out you know I'm gonna be
doing like 56 weeks on the road now
obviously my schedule would be a little
bit different be honest with you I don't
know I do know however that you know
when I was getting ready to do my
special rather than doing one night in
every city you know when I did that
little I played a smaller theater and I
spent a week in Durham like just
Thursday Friday Saturday and I had it
was so much more enjoyable way of doing
the road rather than doing one night
enduro one night and [ __ ] in
Poughkeepsie one night here
it just becomes a [ __ ] thrash and
when you're an older fellow like myself
you know I like going to a place hanging
out with the people seeing where they
eat going to a game that's how I always
[ __ ] did it so I'm gonna try to do
more of that and I was just in Madison
and funny you should bring up going back
to muwah Wisconsin was I haven't been to
Milwaukee and well I guess it was
October that's amazing I can always
remember this it was like October of
2015 so it's been we'll call it December
at this point so it's been 14 months
so definitely in 2017 not only will I be
coming back to Milwaukee I on spending
like 3-4 days there because that
Milwaukee had not only a great cigar bar
it had the best [ __ ] steam of any
place I've ever been to and it was at a
hotel called the Pfister I swear to God
if the hotel is called the Pfister
it's PF is ter if you in Milwaukee dude
I'm telling you man Milwaukee don't
sleep on Milwaukee great people great
food great [ __ ] lakefront property
for a song right and the sickest [ __ ]
steam room you're ever gonna go into you
get your own private like lifestyles of
the rich and famous [ __ ] it's it's
unbelievable so you know when you get to
be my [ __ ] age that's the type of
[ __ ] that's appealing to you on the road
you know what I mean it's not like ah
dude you got to go to Miami they got all
these hot chicks down there I'm a
[ __ ] creepy old married guy
where is there a steam room listen to me
I got tuberculosis I ain't got time for
the hoos anyways so yeah tonight I'm
actually doing the Steve Allen theatre
and whatever the [ __ ] they're calling it
now and I'm just basically running my
whole new hour
I'm so [ __ ] excited I've gotten past
the whole mourning period of missing my
old jokes past a whole now not as funny
as I was on stage you know I took all
the bullets out of the gun I'm shooting
[ __ ] blacks up here this is my
favorite [ __ ] thing in the world I'm
so excited tonight about the show and
just seeing where it goes and I got a
couple of buddies of mine coming down
who are musicians so they're gonna get
to see that whole [ __ ] because I
already told them was I got you guys
want to come down this is gonna this is
gonna be the real deal
this is not the old tried and true
they're all right coping with being
single oh I already like this right here
hey Billy master of [ __ ] it's
I've been single my entire life
I'm into my later 20s and still haven't
found any lady that I really hit it off
with I've struggled with being single
for a long time but I've been working
through it I'm okay with it but I still
have my dark moments my question to you
is when you were single for all those
years did you ever get lonely or feel
alone did you ever think you'd be single
forever what helped you to endure
through those times and how did you cope
with it yes to all of that yep as I
figured some things out I've been doing
bucket lists types of stuff that helps
me get through it yeah dude that's a
great thing to do when you're single go
do all that [ __ ] you want to do because
you know you meet somebody else yeah
yeah you know you might not have the
time this person says I've gone to see
some of my favorite bands play live I've
traveled a little and I've been working
towards finding a career path that I
really enjoy so I believe and I'm doing
some good things but I still have my
days when I suffer through it a little
but I've learned to sit in that pain for
a bit and find good things saying
something dumb at work oh that's the
next one I thought that was a guy
signing off
or the woman whoever the [ __ ] this is
all right my question to you is you've
been single all those years did you ever
get lonely or feel loved here's the
thing I was never lonely for the first I
don't know how many years of my life
until I had a girlfriend and then lost
my girlfriend and then after that that's
the first time I felt like oh I don't
have a chick it's weird
I didn't have my first serious
girlfriend till I was like 23 something
like that 20 to 23 years old so I was
fine with being single and that thing
lasted like I don't know like eight nine
months and how I ended up breaking up
with her and I was right before I
started doing stand-up and I remember
the first six weeks of being like [ __ ]
how long is it gonna take for me to get
over this person and it's weird man like
getting over a person it's like it's
like quitting the booze it's a habit
they're a habit you know what I mean I
always call him at this time and
you got to fill up those [ __ ] times
but you just can't fill them up you kind
of got to go through the morning of them
not being there anymore and then you
start filling them up with other stuff
but like dude I think travels seeing
bands and everything the great thing is
dude the fact that you are lady the fact
that you're single and you feel alone is
a very healthy thing you know I mean now
if you look totally [ __ ] single and
you didn't feel lonely at all well I
guess maybe you know maybe you're just
too [ __ ] someone who doesn't want to
be with anybody that could also because
like you're not out killing people you
know what I mean no you don't feel the
need to hunt you know you're not feeling
that and as long as you're alright with
whatever it is you're doing then you
should be fine dude you're in your
[ __ ] late 20s - trust me someday
you're gonna be married you're gonna
have a [ __ ] kid coming like I got
right now and you're all of a sudden all
your drum videos you're thinking I'm
gonna get rid of those I gotta get rid
of all this [ __ ] I gotta get rid of all
of this stuff and there's this feeling
that I'm having right now will I ever
play drums again but fortunately I
married the coolest woman ever so I just
was able to sit down with her this this
might help you if you're afraid to get
in a relationship because you feel like
you're gonna lose all of this stuff you
just like the person you're with know
what's important I already said to my
wife I said listen here's the deal like
once a week okay you pick a day once a
week when this kid is not sleeping
through the night and you can just go
somewhere get a massage or just go
someplace and [ __ ] sleep or I'll take
the kid and go drive around I'll let you
sleep for [ __ ] hours and hours
whatever the hell it is okay all you got
to do is let me keep playing drums they
can drum lessons in that [ __ ] that'll be
my spa thing cuz I don't really need to
sleep because I'm a [ __ ] lunatic and
also I'll still get to do the road twice
a month and you know I'll use that time
to sleep I'll do my shows at night and
then I'll go right to the hotel and I
will sleep till the [ __ ] cats come
home the cows come whatever the [ __ ]
animal is and then I'll come back
recharged you know what I mean but we we
make sure that we kind of work that
stuff out with each other so if you're
afraid to get in a relationship just
know that there's cool people out there
as long
you I know yeah you never hear me say
this but women in general pretty cool if
you just tell them what the [ __ ] deal
is but I have issues with women so even
as I said that just picturing how many
women just went like oh my god yes like
that annoyed me even though they were
agreeing with me
it's weird I got a lot of [ __ ] issues
so yeah I definitely felt like I was
never gonna meet the one I felt like
there was something wrong with me and
all of this type of [ __ ] just know this
every one of your friends that's in a
relationship is secretly envious of you
even if they're with the right person
that's how much [ __ ] work it is you
know every once in a while you know I
look at [ __ ] you know I look at her I
look at a playboy like Joe DeRosa
and I'll be like god damnit man what the
[ __ ] that he's guy you know I always
kiss keys living the life you know but
that you know you come home and your
wife makes some [ __ ] cookies you're
like yeah this is pretty cool too
alright saying something dumb it works
so what I'm saying to this person you
find if you're in your late 20s the same
way that you have goals with your career
and bucket list stops you have so you
should have some goals about the kind of
person that you want to be with like
women after you actually do [ __ ] like
that women actually sit down and think
about the kind of guys don't do that we
just sort of ping-pong a wrong I'll
stick my [ __ ] dick in that you know
with idiots but if you actually you know
get a little Bill Belichick you know see
what's missing you know from your half
see what you're looking for what do you
want you know do you want a woman that
wants kids do you want a woman that can
cook and your traditional do you want a
career woman like what do you want you
know I can tell you right now if you
want a woman that can cook will actually
sit down and cook oh I'll tell you right
now that's like I don't know
you know like want everyone 70 I don't
know how many years they have that that
1983 draft like women do not women's do
not be cooking anymore
all this feminism [ __ ] it's really a sad
thing but men have you know it's our
fault because we didn't put a value on
it great I'm out there busting my ass
you
pickling cucumbers right we just gave
them [ __ ] making a meal for somebody's
one of the nicest things you could ever
do you know but what happened how we
talk [ __ ] we gave we didn't give her
[ __ ] respect him now lookin they don't
want to cook up be mothers they're out
there running around willy-nilly wearing
pantsuits running and running for
president of the United States I mean
that that's a mad job kid you know the
funniest [ __ ] thing ever is how sick
you have to be to want to be President
the fact that Hillary Clinton is
depressed right now that she didn't get
a job where she was gonna have to put
her head in the pillow every night
knowing she just made a decision that
bombs were just dropped and possibly
landed on somebody's baby and she's
she's depressed that she didn't get that
[ __ ] job it's unbelievable what do
you think her pajamas look like she
definitely has the [ __ ] guy once
right like the flannel lots where in the
pant suits
I like the pant suits I don't know why
everybody gave a [ __ ] about it I always
like rhoda you know Rhoda Mary Tyler
Moore they [ __ ] filled those things
out you know walking around you little
buns ease up against that rayon all
right say something dumb at work saying
something dumb at work okay what do we
got here yeah [ __ ] you guys mind if I
just do the last bit of you know what
that's a kunti move I'll read this and
then I'll do the advertising hey Bill
longtime fan probably listened to you
too much once again you start with the
compliment then you give me the old
[ __ ] shank to the kidney longtime fan
probably listened to you too much
alright too too much when it's too much
that's that's two oohs all right all
right here's my problem I was a I was at
work party I think you mean that a work
party talking to my colleagues I work as
an RN in an ICU okay that's a registered
nurse in an intensive care unit huh I
have some nurses in my family we have a
new to our unit hired joining us but
she's worked as a nurse for 25 years
already my friend said she's joining my
rotation I say out loud in my typical
bill blurt burned
inflection oh Jesus no how jeez another
old broad and I learned there several
colleagues heard this and now every day
is some new twist on my comment some
chirping is fine but half the unit is
over 50 I want some joke comment I don't
want some joke comment to help me haunt
me for years bill how do I get this to
go away
thanks I would just say with them I just
I wouldn't back off it I would just keep
doing the Archie Bunker on geez another
row broader eyeline there and then when
they dig in this lady too old oh good
all year with you menopause there but
you can't do that at work now you can't
do that work now because you're not
making it a safe place oh my god that
alone that alone gave Trump about two
hundred thousand votes [ __ ] adults
saying you're not making this a safe
space that's just [ __ ] did they all
have a meeting and they came up with
that [ __ ] horrific that what was the
second choice I just don't understand
that uh you know something I have to be
honest with you I don't know how you get
out of that and right there that's why I
do what I do for a [ __ ] living
because there's no way I could be in
that level of a childish [ __ ]
environment the people who what did you
mean about that well how many [ __ ]
thoughts have you had in your head today
the old [ __ ] bag that if they would
publicize that you would even still have
a job as a nurse get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah you know you know I just guess
you know women like sweets just come and
just bake a [ __ ] pie or some [ __ ]
anyways I'm sorry going through that I'm
sorry you were quoting me but you know
what you also kind of blamed me a little
bit they would say he listened to me too
much throw a little bit of blame you
want a little peyton manning there we
had protection issues that's what you
just did to me there i don't know how
much SP you're still bringing that you
still bringing that up you should have
heard what I said this morning something
like
I would just do that it is kind of funny
who gives a [ __ ] do you like the job it
all depends on how much you like the job
but what she's old you're all old I
wouldn't [ __ ] any of you you know I
don't know I don't know what I don't
know how to get out of that if anybody
has any suggestions tweet it at me and
I'll [ __ ] retweet it maybe this
person follows me on Twitter and can
help him out would help if I know you're
a man or a woman I have no idea all
right Dollar Shave Club I'm guessing a
man if you're a woman you're the coolest
woman ever that you said that they're
all brought here all right Dollar Shave
Club Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing
affordable raises right to your door
every month so you can get a great shape
but razors aren't the only thing you
need in the bathroom what about some
shower stuff huh
turns out to all the shape club thought
of that too they just came out with a
new line of shower products shampoo and
body wash called the wanderer the
fragrances are unlike anything on the
market they're subtle and actually smell
like real natural ingredients there are
a lot of body washes out there that make
you smell like a teenager this mint and
cedarwood body wash is amazing it makes
you smell incredible it's like you're
eating ice cream next to the fireplace
you got to give it a try what the [ __ ]
is so great about mint and cedarwood
body those two different ones I hope
like you're [ __ ] eatin ice cream over
Ron Burgundy's house rich mahogany you
got to give it a try once you're in the
club you'll see the products are amazing
the service is world-class there's no
long term commitments no hidden fees and
you can cancel whenever you want and
best of all they're giving away a
one-month trial of any one of their
[ __ ] race for a dollar with free
shipping and after that it's just a few
bucks a month get your online dollar
trial at dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / who's next two
more to go o MVM tea movement watches
pronounced
movement was founded on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank the
watchmakers goal is to change the way
consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices with
over 500,000 watches sold to customers
and 160 plus countries around the
[ __ ] world movement watches has
solidified itself as the world's fastest
growing watch company all right
holiday thought status please be
conversational choose one and make this
your own all right I'm gonna choose this
one we get it
fuckos holiday shopping can be [ __ ]
hot
this is me making my own I just say
[ __ ] boston accent but thanks to
movement watches all that gift-giving
horseshit anxiety can disappear with the
press of the button these watches make
the perfect purchase for just about any
person in your life guy or girl and
remember they just start at 95 bucks you
know what even if you don't like
somebody spending ninety five bucks
there's too much money only get this for
people that you care about you know what
I mean
get out everybody else you can get a
[ __ ] bumper sticker alright get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to movement watches
comp slash / this watch has a really
clean design alright seriously evidently
I've been getting compliments on the one
that I don't wear ever since I put it on
now it's the time to step up your watch
game go-to movement watches dot-com / /
join the movement get a $95 watch for
five hundred bucks now five hundred ala
watch for ninety five bucks today lastly
but not leastly stamps calm everybody
out there he's a saint but he doesn't
care about Muslims Jews or [ __ ]
Buddhist people right what about all
those aboriginals whatever the [ __ ] they
worship huh
how come Santa Claus doesn't go to them
you know why cuz they be like oh my god
it's another white man and they [ __ ]
put a poisoned dart enough and it serve
him right
you know it serve him right even though
he didn't do anything he'd be a martyr
you know this big stupid red suit laying
face down in it right
stamps.com what the holidays almost I'm
surprised the government is
tried to set up Santa Claus by sending
him into some area with his indigenous
people just set him up for a fight the
way we did when we took over this
[ __ ] country you know so we could
justify the genocide of those wonderful
people that when they killed a squirrel
they used all of it unlike us what do we
do huh through the inside of the [ __ ]
womp rat and then use the rest as a hat
for what is it goof
stamps.com everybody white people the
frat boys of people I'm sorry stamps.com
what the holidays almost here you don't
have time to go to the post office well
you do but who the [ __ ] wants to go it
will be packed with everyone mailing
holiday gifts and packages so so do what
I do do what I do
you stamps.com instead with stamps calm
you can avoid all the hassle man going
to the post office during the busy
holiday season
buying print official US posters using
your own computer or printer print the
postage for any letter or package the
instance you need it then the mailman
picks it up you never have to go to the
post office again it's a [ __ ] dream I
use stamps calm whenever I'm sending out
any of my posters anytime I'm selling
some [ __ ] at the end of a [ __ ] show
any time I think to myself you know what
I haven't I haven't shaked enough sweaty
[ __ ] palms of complete strangers you
know what I mean I want to feel that
warm armpit of a taller person as they
put their arm around me sitting right on
my shoulder seeping into my [ __ ]
button-down that's when I send out all
my posters everybody you can print the
postage and all that [ __ ] then the
mailman picks it up alright right now I
can do you better I can get you an even
better offer than what's on the home
page sign up for stamps calm right now
and use my last name Bert to get a four
week trial plus $110 bonus software that
includes postage in the digital scale go
to Stan's com click on the microphone
stop the homepage and type in BER that
stamps comm enter ber okay it's over
alright let's let's finish off the rest
of these here Oh key dokey fun times in
Syria Billy the [ __ ] its Martin from
Sweden thank you for this podcast no
worries it's been more than ten years
since I was almost raped in Syria what
the [ __ ] although time passes the story
seems to never get old
all right you know I really just gonna
[ __ ] with me on this goddamn level here
am I supposed to believe this is true
how time flies it's like you're looking
back fondly on this this is weird I was
17 when me and my class went on a school
trip to Syria puts in parentheses Middle
East's go [ __ ] yourself
Jesus I know I know American I know
we're serious all right one day all of
my classmates were out snorkeling I
stayed in the hostel bed because I had a
fever two aspirins later I found myself
out looking for my class in sauna like
temperatures with a foolish mindset my
blonde blue-eyed nature fake figured the
aspirin had cured my fever so I was in
quite good spirits for about seven miles
of searching for the other Swedes this
is creeping me out
now the fever was kicking back and in at
this point and I'd given up my endeavors
of snorkelling I didn't know where I was
or how to get back to my hostel at that
moment a taxi pulled over the driver
asked if I wanted to get a lift I said I
didn't have any money to offer but he
insisted that no money was needed for
the ride oh Jesus is right yes I fever
and good amounts of gullibility led me
to step into the cab and off we went
hi welcome to Syria the taxi guy said
you are very beautiful I didn't want to
be rude so I said thanks back at him
then he asked me if I liked women sure I
replied then he asked if I like big
women sure I said he said ah you like
big because same with your dick he said
what at this point I regretted getting
to that what the [ __ ] ah you like big
because same with your dick he said ok I
thought this was a woman so it's a guy
and now there's dude oh jesus here we go
at this point I regret getting to the
taxi very much in the moment after he
was reaching for my package while he was
driving
oh dude that's Oh were you in the front
seat
that's when you
do what was that [ __ ] Schwarzenegger
movie where he gets on the plane with
that guy and he pretends to tie his shoe
when he comes up with the elbow of death
and drives the spine of his nose into
his brain and then puts his little
[ __ ] Tommy Bahama hat over his face
and he goes don't disturb him he's dead
tired that's what you needed to do was
that rod deal I think he needed to go
raw deal there anyways I say no stop I
said but the track see driver was very
super system he wondered why he couldn't
touch my penis like I owed him the right
to do so I was feeling extremely
vulnerable being a teenager foreigner
and having a high fever at all I shouted
in and stopped the car but he kept on
going dude you got to start going Dave
the hammer Schultz here right you got a
[ __ ] he got to start swinging man but
he kept on going I thought about jumping
out of the car but I was it was going
way too fast I also didn't want to start
a fight and risk crashing the car ah
Jesus at some point dude you got to pick
your poison did it have airbags picture
pictures of Taliban rape Cades with Pulp
Fiction [ __ ] suits and gag balls was
entering my mind as the taxi car
continued to drive on without any intent
to pull over this is really happening oh
my lord I thought to myself luckily we
came to a traffic light and I managed to
get out of the car and on the pavement I
started running when I heard him
screaming at me one Syrian pound mr. Oh
God now you got to get paid for getting
you got to pay him for moving less than
you I got over the experience pretty
soon and it have not affected my life to
any extent
no [ __ ] way people sometimes want me
to tell the almost rape story and give
impressions of the taxi driver I can't
help to think how unfunny it would be if
I were a girl almost getting raped in
Syria yeah but you're a guy so it's
[ __ ] hell everything that happens to
a guy is hilarious nobody gives a [ __ ]
my question to you is why is this kind
of a wiseass story kind of funny if it
happened to men but awful in every way
if it happened to a woman your thoughts
on that after you go [ __ ] yourself
PS say hi to lovey
this is why it's funny because you're
able to fight them off it's a guy with
an accent grabbing your dick when you
tell the story of my friend my friend
just like your dick beep beep right it's
just hilarious I remember one night we
were down the Comedy Cellar we were all
telling stories about getting molested
as kids and it was one of the funniest
nights I've ever had it was so [ __ ]
cathartic and we would just cry and
laughing and I remember all the comics
where you know I don't know had a
different upbringing we're looking at it
like it was [ __ ] up but it was [ __ ]
hilarious to me and if you told me this
story I would be laughing my ass off is
still knowing that you you probably have
some sort of [ __ ] issue and all
depends it all depends you know if that
was the first person that ever touched
you you know if no girl ever gave you a
[ __ ] the fact that was the first guy
that ever did it you know his hairy
[ __ ] hand coming over you know that
could possibly [ __ ] you up but you know
if you had a little bit of sexual
activity maybe it doesn't you know it's
kind of like you know if you're a relief
pitcher and you got a you got some saves
under your belt you let up a homerun
yeah give me another [ __ ] ball but if
that's your first [ __ ] pitch I mean
that could [ __ ] with you why is it not
funny uh when it happens to a woman's
the same reason why it's like watching a
guy get punched in the head is [ __ ]
funny you know if he was like talking
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] funny you know what I
mean but like you know kids women
animals like this just never anything
funny about watching them get abused but
this just something hilarious about guys
I would say the reason why you get
having your dick grabbed and get
molested is funny is big the same reason
why the Three Stooges is funny you know
imagine the Three Stooges if it was
women you know grabbing each other by
the hair would slap at the face maybe
that'd be a little funny I don't know
it's just like a guy thing
we like slapstick and there's just
something funny about him grabbing you
[ __ ] stick in some car and then he
charged you one Syrian pound you know
what it really comes down to is I
imagine being gay is not accepted even
remotely in Syria so this guy thought
like I
even if this doesn't go down or if it
does go down this story leaves this
country and goes back to Sweden so in
the way I want to say the cab driver was
the victim and not you and stop being so
selfish now I'm [ __ ] with you I'm
sorry that happened to you um we're
gonna do I mean I mean you were kind of
asking for cuz you were on cold
medication you know I'm gonna blame the
victim here well I mean what were you
wearing I don't know dude that's one of
the more I don't want to say that's one
of the more [ __ ] up stories I've ever
heard but yeah that just goes into that
file I've heard enough of those once
yeah that's why it's not funny
so I would actually say that you are
[ __ ] up there's no way you're not
[ __ ] up cuz that happened to you and
there's there's that feeling where it's
just like why is that funny when that
happens to a guy and then you feel like
you can't [ __ ] that you should just
yeah you know I'm over it like why would
that's a horrific [ __ ] thing that
happened to you and I'm even like
glancing over the whole thing because
it's a guy like a you know [ __ ] shake
it off shake it off and that's part of
growing up you have a paper route or
something like that there'll be some
weirdo coming at you junk at some point
well that's just how it is I remember
when that [ __ ] um that lady cut the
dudes dick off and put it in the garbage
disposal one of those shows it's not the
view I think it's the talk the asian
lady she was reading it and as she was
reading the details they were all
snickering laughing and I remember the
bit I was doing what if some guy cut a
woman's titty off and threw it the
garbage disposal I mean they would have
done a week-long special on that and
they would have tried to help the lady
out raise some money to get her a
prosthetic you know what I mean so a bra
wouldn't be all lopsided that's what the
[ __ ] they do what happens to a guy it's
just [ __ ] hilarious and I also think
that that's why guys are so [ __ ]
funny you know cuz you know if a woman
gets molested it's a tragedy if it
happens to a guy it's a sketch we really
don't have any options you just got to
shake it off man you know I haven't said
all that dude I'm sorry that happened to
you I'm sure you're emotionally [ __ ]
up about
but I would love to hear that story one
time because I want to hear you
imitating the guy you know and then
listen to everybody interrupting so wait
you how fast were you going dude you
couldn't jump out of the car and then
everybody be laughing going yeah but you
jumped out then he'd be like holding on
to your dick like steers half in the car
half out of the car right stretching out
you dick you know then you have one of
those needle dicks because it's not
gonna give you any more girth he's just
gonna say that that's what the whole
[ __ ] thing would be and you know all
your friends would laugh and say that
you wanted it you know what I mean why
didn't you sit in the back like a normal
person why did you sit up front you know
that's what guys would do and they would
laugh you know you just laugh your way
through it so anyways I guess I'm gonna
stop there on the I can't let's stop on
something positive once again I have two
benefits that are coming up to two
friends of mine that are no longer here
Pete coming Memorial is going to be
December 6th at the Laugh Factory I will
tweet that link and the Patrice O'Neal
the five year anniversary of his passing
is today and the one truly positive
thing that came out of that is we get to
remember him and we get to see our
friends and we get to raise some money
for his loved ones every year and it's
gonna be February 21st to Tuesday 2017
at the New York City Center thank you to
all who take the time to check it out
and buy some tickets means the world to
me that's it go [ __ ] yourselves oh by
the way if you want to donate to this
podcast and not have to give any money
if you're doing some Christmas shopping
on Amazon go to Bill burr com first
click on the podcast page you click on
the Amazon link it doesn't cost you any
any extra money I just get credit for
driving traffic there if you want to do
it I get it if you don't I understand
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday